hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video schon im titel ein
warum ist da fordert sondern laute musik
ich weiß nicht ob er das hört aber
irgendwie veranstalten unsere nachbarn
im garten fest ich möchte nicht stört so
was nicht ich finde es cool wenn die
nachbarin titel eingeblendet und zwar
die kreativsten musicals ich hab das ja
auch schon zu den besten und zu den
schlimmsten unsere peinlichsten musicals
gemacht nicht irgendwie auf der
plattform ist er gefunden habe und beim
durchstöbern ist nur heute wieder so
aufgefallen es gibt echt ein paar leute
die sich da wirklich mega gedanken
machen und vor allem das letzte musical
diva sich heute zeigen werde jetzt
einfach nur von einer gottheit
erschaffen wort aber ich würde sagen ich
glaube gar nicht lange um gefangen
werden damit dem ersten musical dieses
musical ist von rudi mancuso und zwar
habe ich denn hier glaube ich schon in
den teil die besten musicals erwähnt ich
weiß nicht ob ich alles zu den
rangenommen hatte ich glaube ich hatte
einen von orbitz angenommen das ist eine
vision animations- puppen channel von
ihm auch und dieser typ sprüht einfach
vor kreativität also ich hab das ja
gerade gesehen er hat die kamera wird
gezwitschert dann von soundso gemacht
und dabei war es in der anderen kamera
und ganz im rennen ist er dann wieder
nach vorne gegangen sind ist es für sie
quasi immer drum herum geht und die
ganze zeit weitergehen nicht einfach
negativ auf die idee zu kommen vor allem
er spielt da irgendwie ein trommler ist
da spielt keyboard oder macht er dieses
trompeter das ist einfach mega leisen
der typ ist einfach kreativ und
talentiert und keine ahnung was ich bei
dir einfach mega deswegen ist das das
erste musical die was ich euch heute von
den kreativkursen ich zeige und wir
machen direkt weiter mit dem 2 dieses
musicals von säckingen den hatte ich
auch in dem paar die besten musicals und
ihr seht schon dass mir daraus wirklich
ein paar leute ins auge gestochen sind
in diesem musical verbindet er quasi
einmal
seine filmischen aspekte zusammen mit
dem hashtag way life music ally wo es
darum geht dass man zeigt wie man aus
dem bett kommen weil das wasser der
tägliche ablauf eines tages von einem
selbst ist und er macht das ganz cool
und zwar fügte halt diese becker
geräusche ein die dann so als ob er
aufsteht und hat so eine weiß rote
bettdecke kuschelt sich damit noch mal
rein und fällt dann aus dem bett und
habe dann wirklich ein weißes t-shirt
eine rote rose an ultra coole ideen muss
man einfach erstmal ob kommen und
andererseits ruf und das erstmal visuell
so darstellen köln also das hat auf
jeden fall nicht in der erde gemacht
sondern wirklich irgendwie after effects
denk ich mal aber dafür ist der typische
auf bekannte macht er mittlerweile auch
auto werbungen und alle auf jeden fall
auch ein ultra kreatives musical und wir
machen direkt weiter mit dem vierten
musical vielleicht kennt ihr diese
person und zwar das falco punch ich weiß
nicht genau wie er ausgesprochen wird
aber auf jeden fall es ist ein deutscher
ich hab mir jetzt nicht extra ein
musical rausgesucht was sich ultra geil
fand von ihm weil eigentlich jeder
kandidat den ich heute bei den
kreativsten musical ist mit am start
habe hat eigentlich nur kreative musiker
ließen geht einfach mal auf die musical
die profile von julia mancuso sein king
oder von falco punch dass das sind
wirklich kunstwerke dabei also ich muss
wirklich sagen ohne mich jetzt bei den
leuten hier einschlagen zu wollen das
ist nicht fair dass wirklich auf jeden
fall besser als das was dieser jacob
sotirios und diese anderen haben wir da
machen was falsch gemacht hat ist jetzt
natürlich nicht so etwas krass ist wie
sehen dass ich nie mit after effects
bearbeitet oder dass man probleme
wirklich noch keyboard und einsamkeit
spielt und so aber er hat einfach mit
der app musical ganz cool gearbeitet und
zwar noch mit diesem drehen mit der hand
und dann dass er quasi das einmal
mit der taste macht oder dann im bild
ist und das hat dann quasi das wort
links aus werden da kommt er von rechts
wieder rein das bin ich einfach mega
cool die ideen sind nicht einfach nein
weil ich meine musical ist er selber so
ein bisschen so gestalter deswegen
durfte er hier natürlich auch nicht
fehlen
übrigens streiten weil die kommentare
welches musical i am allerbesten fall
von denen denen ich den ich die ich euch
und zeige
lisa und lena sind auch gedacht
einige hätten die beiden ja dafür dass
sie als zu jung wild und da keine ahnung
davon haben dieses richtig machen und
das ist doch aber auch nicht
verständlich sein dass dieser erfolg
haben aber ich finde es ehrlich gesagt
hol weise einfach eine positive er
überbringt die beiden plattformen hier
zu dem lied we don't talk anymore und
die machen das echt nice also diese
ganzen kurios ja nicht so dass beide
jetzt gegen die nebeneinander stehen und
in sachen machen sondern dass sie auch
miteinander interagieren oder teilweise
so dann haben sie das hingekriegt dein
herz in die so genau zu haben den herzen
hingekriegt und die schauspieler anhalt
wirklich so ein bisschen zu den lyrics
vom text bei dem text geht es halt da
oben zu schauen sondern dem motto wir
lieben uns nicht mehr richtig wir reden
gar nicht mehr richtig und die machen
das auch echt zu gehen so auseinander da
gehen dann wieder so zusammen machen
dieses herz und setzt auch die kämpfen
finde ich einfach mega cool sehr kreativ
dargestellt ist es mir sich viel zeit
aber einfach anders kreativ als sie
bisher gezeigt habe war dass man sein
kind beispielsweise ist einfach und
nachbearbeitet und herr mega kreativ und
mega talentiert und cool dargestellt
worden und die beiden haben es einmal
direkt so vor der kamera gemacht oder
einen einzigen schnitt zu setzen aber es
ist ein original datei megacool nicht
dann habe ich mir gerade geredet
[Musik]
dieses video das von baker das ist einer
der bekanntesten user weltweit
und ich finde seine musical ist einig
und racoon zwei ich würde jetzt nicht
hinter kreativ abstempelt aber das hier
eigentlich schon es ist auch kein cut
vorhanden es ist nicht kratzt oder
nachbarn ist es einfach nur ein video
aber ich finde einfach so etwas
aufzunehmen in der öffentlichkeit ist
einfach dass dafür braucht man als auch
in form von james ltd die die pdk blaha
war er läuft einfach mit seinem fahrrad
so ampera und am ende schmeißt er sich
dann auch noch hin und das bin ich
einfach cool ist kreativ dargestellt und
ich dachte jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
einen kontrast zu denen die ich euch
bisher gezeigt habe die wirklich ultra
krankenwagen finde ich das einfach in
der weise kreativ dass er sich als
einfach getraut hat weil ich würde mich
das nicht trauen
nur -
dieses musical wurde zudem ethische von
port mirroring justin bieber war es
glaube ich bin mir da gerade gar nicht
so ganz sicher wurde auf jeden fall dazu
gemacht und es halt einfach so einen
stop motion dingen also nicht komplett
stop motion von wegen da sind nur
irgendwelche bilder und die werden
aneinandergereiht sondern wirklich so
kleine videos immer so für zwei drei
millisekunden gefilmt und dann neues
video und dann zählt er die h ich zeige
es euch hier nochmal bin ich cool weil
sein mal was anderes ist und man es
nicht allzu oft sieht deswegen habe ich
halt versucht auch jetzt hier heute
nicht lieben videos von der king und die
malkurse einzunehmen sondern weg ist ein
bisschen variete war die wölfe sind
abwechslung einzupacken und deswegen
habe ich sie mir drin und ich bin's
megacool wir kommen jetzt zum letzten
news ich meine damen und herren ich muss
wirklich sagen dieses musical ist von
einer person die ich über alles liebe
also es gibt wirklich keinen user
weltweit den ich mehr schaum und mir
mehr zu gemüte führen diesen er wird das
ganze aber mit seiner leidenschaft
kreativität und einfach er ist süß und
ich mag hin und ich zeige es euch jetzt
einfach mal
[Musik]
und mit bei music ally scheint es dann
okay
[Musik]
und dann tun ist sich selber drei höchst
das ganze mal so überlegen ich versuche
bei music heli wirklich kreative sachen
zu machen und wenn ich meinen eigenen
content ist kreativ ansehen würden als
cool dann irgendwie auch falsch
verstehen ich habe mir einfach bei
diesem pokemon musical wie mega höhe
gegeben
es wird zwar auch von mir sicher die als
symbol und hat über 120000 lights aber
deswegen checken
danke das war 10 vom video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen hat es getan hat lassen leider
schaffen wir im prozess nicht warum
schreit china noch mal eine ganz kurze
zwischen die sache hier bevor das video
ein zweiter beziehungsweise zu ende geht
ich habe eine ganz kurze frage an euch
und zwar mit dieser musicali content ja
allgemein auf youtube nicht gerettet
aber es ist ein bisschen komisch von der
seite angeschaut sagen ich mache mich
interessiert einfach ob ihr fern von
meinen videos zum musical seid also wenn
ich euch sowas wie besten oder die
schlimmsten oder die kreativsten
musikhandys vorstelle an der stelle
angemerkt muss ich sagen dass es mir
selber ultra viel spaß macht weil ich
alles magen von wegen ich suche etwas
raus wenn ich irgendwie im bett lege
oder wenn nicht schiller oder wenn ich
in der bahn sitzen mache darüber einfach
nachher video weil es ziemlich einfach
nur super arbeitsaufteilung ist ich hab
das ja beispielsweise früher so gemacht
dass ich sehr viele kommentare heraus
gesucht habe und die kommentiert habe
oder instagram bilder nachgestellt habe
und das ist einfach super kurzem ich
selber weil ich die sachen quasi
raussuchen kann und danach darüber
einfach ein video machen
deswegen machen wir jetzt eben eine ganz
kurze umfrage damit ich selber weiß ob
ihr dieses musical die content feiert
oder nicht bayer haben ob ich davon noch
mehr machen sollen oder nicht schreibt
weil er die kommentare im uci kino wenn
ihr bock haben auf mehr musicali konnten
um das feiert so wie ich das
beispielsweise heute gemacht haben oder
bei dem video massig momente verlinken
werde ohne kommentiert mit kein musical
ich mir dadurch dass ihr kein woche böse
kind von mir hat weil über die leistung
des 3
immer schlecht regeln viele leiden hier
einfach weil sie irgendwie mich cool
finden und wir in dieser weise nicht
uncool finden darüber kann man umfragen
einfach schlecht machen und dieses
youtube umfrage tool spannend bei mir
einfach mega ich kann das mit ihren
karten denen wir derzeit nicht
aktivieren deswegen macht es einfach
über ein kommentar mit music oder kein
musical und dann weiß ich ja auch davon
mehr wollen oder nicht
ja und jetzt mal flug hat die
ehrenkarten findet ihr es war ihr
eingeblendet da klickt mal bitte drauf
weil da könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren
und ich brauche glaube ich ihnen nur
noch 4000 abonnenten oder so bis zu zwei
millionen mark
hier findet ihr das video die besten
musicals eingeblendet dabei unter
anderem auch nicht von säckingen dabei
von dem ich gerade das aus dem bett
gezeigt habe und klickt auf jeden fall
mal drauf ist auf jeden fall cool
geworden
ciao